أجنبي
los angeles
[تصفيق]
هذا مبني على الشيء الذي كان
في قلب الدين المصري
عندما ماتت ووضعت في مقبرتك
كان لديك 12 ساعة لتتجول في
العالم السفلي من الظلام إلى النور
وتواجه آلهة الفوضى.  من
أراد أن يوقفك
إذا نجحت في تلك الرحلة
ليس فقط أنك عشت إلى الأبد
بسعادة ولكنك أنقذت مصر ليوم آخر
[موسيقى]
يقود ملك الشمس توت خلال تلك
الرحلة ونذهب معه نحن داخل
القبر و  في كل مكان حولنا ، نجد
أنك تعرف الآلهة التي تحاول
تدميرنا من خلال الجفاف من خلال
العنف من خلال الطاعون من خلال
ثعبان 360 درجة الذي يحيط بالغرفة بأكملها
[موسيقى]
في الأيام الخوالي عندما بدأوا في تقديم عروض
توت كانوا أساسًا  ركزوا على
نظرة ما وجدناه داخل القبر ، انظروا
إلى الذهب ، انظروا إلى الجواهر ، انظروا إلى
ذلك فكرنا لماذا لا نحاول أن نجعل
الناس يفهمون ما وراءه كل هذا
لماذا
وضع الفرعون في قبر لماذا نحن  وضعت كل
هذه الأشياء هناك ما الرحلة التي كان
على الفرعون أن يواصلها
[موسيقى]
لدينا شاشات تليفزيونية بها كما
نسميها حقائقنا العشرين التي تعمل باللمس
وتستمر في عرض أشياء عنه ،
لدينا أشياء تبدو وكأنها
أعمدة مصرية ولكن  إن تاريخ مصر
وخاصة خلفية
الدين يتدحرج عليه إذا
وقفت حرفيًا دون حراك لمدة ثلاث
دقائق وشاهدته ستحصل على دورة
مكثفة في مصر
[موسيقى]
هي
لوس أنجلوس
[تصفيق]